once again the media accidentally
presents a stark contrast between their
phony storytelling and real life that's
going on around you
this weekend the Press published stories
about the premiere of the film The Joker
linking it to white rage It was as if
they'd already had these pieces written
beforehand by the same CNN intern while
they hallucinatin grim narratives one
played out for real on the streets of
New York
a madman murdered four homeless men just
blocks from the mayor's office
presumably the madmen hadn't seen the
Joker he was a young deranged transient
with 14 priors this crime was a result
of a bureaucracy that washes its hands
of both the homeless and the criminally
insane allowing tragedy to follow both I
haven't seen the film but I know the
plot the Joker suffers from mental
illness but due to budget cuts the
government slashes his treatment that
seems a more relevant plot point than
race and it underscores Saturday night's
mayhem in American cities government's
idea of treatment is the streets the
Saturday night Massacre won't lead the
news because the homeless aren't the
prettiest victims and the perp isn't the
ideal mustache twirling villain but it's
not a movie it's today's world run by
those who prefer to punish offensive
words rather than prevent demonic deeds
so the most desperate are left to suffer
until they turn on themselves it's no
story from DC Comics but the other DC a
reality born from an abdication of
responsibilities by a hopeless
bureaucracy which is maybe why the mayor
and the media prefers the comic book